ich denke dass mittlerweile alle unter
euch vor ort ein battle royale kennen
sollten das ist ein spiel was in letzter
zeit einen extremen hype hat einen
extremen push durch die ganzen leute die
spielen was allerdings auch sehr viele
leute kennen es der akinator und der
akinator versucht herauszufinden an die
person die an die man denken deswegen
weil er davon herren stellen wir uns
heute der challenge herauszufinden ob
die akinator fortnight kennt bevor wir
allerdings schauen ob das auch wirklich
der fall schauen wir erstmal ob der
akinator mich überhaupt noch kennt also
wurde die figur durch youtube berühmt ja
ich wurde durch youtube berühmt ist
deine figur weiblich
ich bin natürlich männlich hatte eine
figur einen freund namens julian nein so
weit kommt noch alter ist die figur
blond ja ich bin blond hat eine für
etwas mit sex habe sich nun der die
figur schon einmal geküsst habe ich
schon mal ein spiegel geküsst würde ich
auch sagen er nein hat er nicht wieder
über 1000 abonnenten ja hat denn die
figur früher unterrichtet hinein hat
eine für das mit griechischer mythologie
zu tun
es gibt einige leute die meinen nicht
sein gott ich würde auch hier mit nein
antworten hat er nicht nur einen hund
als haustier nein aber schön wer als
kann er die figur sich bewegen ja das
will ich auch hinkriegen ich trage
eigentlich nicht so häufig mützenich
stammen aus dem internet ist bin mit
niemandem zusammen ich habe keinen sohn
ich bin über 18 ich war nicht bei dsds
dabei ich bin nicht 17 ich wohne ich in
hamburg
das ging aber auch mal nach vier fragen
dass ich da erkannt wurde youtube-videos
mache ich auch nicht ich wohne in
deutschland ich habe mir schon mal die
haare gefärbt ist eine figur ein flotter
york man schon so sagen ich es ist
abgestürzt nur wenige minuten später das
ist vollkommen korrekt ich habe keinen
sohn und auch keine tochter ich bin
männlich ja ich fahre keinen delorean
der kanal bei mir heißt konkret ich bin
nicht älter als 45 ich mache keine
minecraft let's play sich kommt eine
figur aus minecraft
nee ich komme aus bielefeld ich komme
nicht aus kreuzberg ich mache minecraft
videos ab und zu ist seine figur
mitglieder einer mafia nein ich habe
keine berühmten bruder oder schwester
ich bin immer noch keine figuren
minecraft ich spiele auch nicht einfach
sky braucht auch keine zigaretten ich
spiele nicht maßgabe dass ich meinen
sims charakter ich wohne nicht in
washington ja ich sage zu beginn hallo
mein name ist luke wieso weißt du es
dann jetzt doch nicht ich habe bei wago
vier mitgespielt ich stamme aus keinem
spiel
ich mag nicht buchhalter percy jackson
ja ich lebe in europa ich wurde in
deutschland geboren ich habe nichts mit
uns zu tun ich spiele nicht in minecraft
sky mit ich habe in meinen 23
mitgespielt bei varro zwei ich habe
etwas mit kontrast zu tun kommt deine
figur den tomatensaft geld
den was tomaten deswegen würde ich auch
mit ja antworten ja man ey com endlich
hat er mich ja raten nach 4000 fragen ja
das bin ich freunde ich wurde fast eine
million mal gespielt wie klicken
allerdings mal wieder neu aufspielen
ich bin nicht aus holz diesmal versuche
ich übrigens vorne zu finden ich habe
nicht im januar geburtstag ich kenne die
person nicht versöhnlich ich bin nicht
männlich ich bin nicht über 18 ich habe
keine zwei augen ich weiß nicht wie ich
aussehe
ich habe einen namen ja ich kann nicht
sprechen ist bekannt ja also ich habe
das im internet ja sagt er dass mit
dieser technologie zu tun spanischen ein
sprich deine figur mit dir was meine
figur sitzt auf einer wolke meine figur
ist auch nicht größer als 1 meter 60 sie
ist auch nicht eher dick sie hat nichts
mit religion zu tun sie es nicht in der
porno szene bekannt sie ist das msn
männchen wahrscheinlich dass oder ein
ford neid ist auch keine hübsche frau
fordert ist auch nicht älter als zwanzig
vorteil ist ja ein bisschen verrückt sie
spielt nicht wahr
robot sie kommt nicht aus oder doch doch
sie kommt doch aus dem amerikanischen
content meine figur etwas mit videospiel
zu tun
sie liebt keine deutsche schlager sie
hat keinen fall etwas mit technik zu tun
sie ist nicht über 120 sie kommen in dem
buch vor sie gehört nicht konkreter sie
sich über 15
sie hat nichts erfunden die jasid galt
20 fordert hat etwas mit spielen zu tun
sie stammt aus einem spiel in dem app
store sie ist super sell
das sind die gründer von clash of plants
allerdings ist es nicht das was ich
gerade suche meine figur ist nicht
erwachsen sie ist kein alien die sich
zum tode verurteilt worden sie kann ich
weit springen sie ist nicht aus metall
sie ist und ein videospiel ja sehr nett
hat etwas mit musik zu tun es ist nicht
er und sie hat nicht tragisch geendet
sie komme ich aus minecraft es ist ein
auch nicht geometrie des ford wurde
definitiv durch youtube bekannt ist
jünger als 30
vorteil machte allerdings keine videos
ist eine figur ein drachen ein auch
nicht habe ich noch nie getroffen
steht eine frau an der spitze eines
großen teams nicht aus italien
sie hat auch nichts mit tieren zu tun
die sich kreativ sie hat deine figur
schon mal auf dem minecraft server
feuerkraft punkt eu gespielt
portman hat etwas mit einem
computerspiel zu tun sie hatten nichts
mit minecraft sie tun ja mit
elektrizität schon hätte keine rüstung
es ist auch nicht dass stars table spiel
ich weiß nicht ob ihr euch noch daran
erinnert allerdings habe ich ja auch mal
stars table hochgeladen ja okay zum in
rennen wissen die dass sich ein
kompletter spaß den rennen bin ich bin
jetzt gerade schon so weit beim akinator
dass er mir sagt jo ist eine figur hier
irgendwo mit dabei ist sie allerdings
nicht
ich sage meine figur ist nicht in der
liste und sage jetzt einfach ich denke
an bord night battle royale wow jetzt
zeigt er mir vorschläge an
und das einzige was da vor neid ist ist
das hier fortnight damit menschenrechte
sind ziemlich abstoßend
an der stelle wo ich das video ist
allerdings auch beenden meine damen und
herren wenn es euch gefallen hat das
gerne mal einen like da besteht ihr
selber fordert schreibt die kommentare
und jetzt kommt das auto okay das war's
jetzt hier vom video hier können jetzt
hier in einen kanal abonnieren oder
meinen stärken jetzt findet ihr zwei
andere videos und wenn ihr schon
abonnent seid könnt ihr auf die glocke
klicken dann willkommen die
benachrichtigungen
[Musik]